No
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah. Continuing
in
the book of Salah. Now that we've began
or now that we've begun the book of
Salah, the author is going to take a
slight detour. The reason for this is
that this book is geared towards the
general masses of the Muslim. It's not a
pure textbook.
A pure textbook form of the fukah is
usually very cut and dry. It's very
interesting to people who are advanced
and it is very complex, complicated and
uninteresting
to someone who is a beginner. All right,
this book is geared towards
the general masses. That's why its name
is Elwis, right? the the the concise the
concise the summary of Phil and this is
why only the most major issues are
mentioned there's a lot of peripheral
issues that are not mentioned that even
I had to add and
the issues are not presented as more
than one opinion or more than one
possibility is just mentions the ruling
and it's most obvious evidence ends and
it moves on. Because of this, the author
is going to take us on a bit of a detour
is a very important detour. And that is
he's going to discuss
what is usually not found in the books
of usually this is reserved for books on
books geared more towards
geared more towards admonishment or
geared more towards contemplation or
meditation. Right? more so than books
geared towards. And so he is going to
discuss now
the
importance of salah in Islam. This is
not something that's usually discussed
in books of it's not his place. Right?
And then he's going to discuss the
ruling
of a person who abandons salah. Someone
who does not pray at all. and someone
who prays
cons consistently.
And then we're going to add a third
which is someone who prays consistently
but misses prayers. What is the ruling
on each of these three?
The author says
the position of salah in Islam.
What what position does Salah hold in
Islam? He says,
[Silence]
Ramadan.
He says on the authority of Abdah
Abdahbar,
may Allah be pleased with him and his
father who narrates that the messenger
of Allah sallall.aii Wasallam said Islam
has been built upon five pillars.
[Silence]
Islam.
Islam has been built upon five
foundations, fundamentals, five pillars.
All of these are correct and all of them
have been narrated with those different
words. Islam has been built upon five
pillars.
the testimony that none is rightfully
worshiped but Allah and that Muhammad is
the messenger of Allah and the
establishment of prayer and the giving
of zaka the hajj the pilgrimage to the
house the house meaning the house of
Allah and Mecca and fasting the month of
Ramadan.
So these are the five pillars of Islam.
We've all heard of these, correct?
what does this mean? The prophet
sallall.aii wasallam was asked to define
Islam.
Define it.
It's if you could imagine yourself right
now,
someone told you, tell me
what is the mosque,
the MCCT
mosque,
right? You could define that in a couple
of ways. This building that we're in
right now, we could define it in a
couple of ways. We could define it by
the people that go there.
We could define it by its exact
definition in city hall
or its exact name in city hall with its
address and coordinates.
Or we could define it by its most
prominent features. Right? Someone says,
"Tell me about the mosque in the MCCT
mosque." And I said, "Well, it's, you
know, it's got a gold dome. It looks
this. It's about this size. It is
located at the following place. I have
defined it for you, but I've defined it
by its outward appearance. Or I could
define it by its location. Or I could
define it by the people that go there. I
could say it's the masid that so and so
goes to or the masid that so and so is
the imam there or the masid that so and
so is
built. for instance. This is all
correct definitions,
right? And that's how things are defined
in the Quran. Usually, they're either
defined by the by the by the path or
defined by the people that are on the
path or defined by the parameters of the
path. Here
Islam is defined
by its most prominent rights.
From the outside looking in, who is a
Muslim? A Muslim is the one who has
these five pillars.
The testimony that none is rightfully
worshiped but Allah. That Muhammad is
the messenger of Allah. The
establishment of prayer. The giving of
zaka. making Hajj and fasting Ramadan.
Notice that every one of these pillars
is what is referred to as
meaning it's an individual obligation.
It's an obligation on individuals and
communities
contrary to other major
pillars of Islam jihad for instance
or a or like
you know slaughtering etc. These are
all major rights of Islam. However, they
are obligated upon a community as a
whole not individuals.
As far as each individual person is
concerned, these are the five pillars of
Islam. So we see that the huge
position that salah occupies
is that it has been made a pillar of
Islam.
And this means that if a person does not
have this pillar, they fail to fulfill
this pillar
that their Islam is at best
highly deficient,
not ready for
not ready for presentation to Allah.
And at worst, a person's Islam could
even be invalid.
if the first pillar was
compromised,
if that is compromised, it entirely
compromises a person's religion. Their
entire Islam is compromised.
And so salah is a huge major right of
Islam.
And it is arguably the most major right
of Islam after a shahad. And as we'll
hear in the in the following days,
inshallah,
this is the only act of worship.
This is the only act of worship
that the scholars differ on whether a
person can still be Muslim if they have
completely abandoned salah. Every other
act of worship, it's a difference. It's
the majority of the scholars or all
of the scholars agree that this person
is still a Muslim. However, their Islam
is highly deficient except for salah.
Salah as the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam has mentioned a person who does
not pray at all. This compromises a
person's Islam to the core to the point
that it is a difference of opinion on
whether this person can either still be
a Muslim or not. And we will discuss
that of course in greater detail. But
this shows the incredible position that
Salah has. And if salah has that
position,
imagine how critical it is to make sure
that it's right,
to make sure that we do it correctly.
There is nothing more important for us
to learn to make sure is perfect
than salah.
[Silence]
I think I'm